if you simply ran out of things to do in
vanilla destiny to its first DLC
expansion curse of Osiris adds a few new
activities for you to take on but aside
from the short but fun raid lair almost
all the new stuff in cursive Osiris the
story missions strikes crucible Maps
adventures and weapons don't add
anything substantial or interesting to
destiny to to make it worth revisiting
cursive Osiris picks up right after the
end of the base game's campaign as far
as your level goes you could go directly
from the end of the red war story to
cursive Osiris's campaign which requires
a power level of 200 to 220 without
having to grind much in between for
newcomers or PC players who've had less
time with the game it's a comfortable
bridge for leveling up between the lower
level vanilla content in the high level
in-game activity is like the nightfall
those in-game activities are a different
story but we'll get to that in a bit as
a result though curse of Osiris is story
missions feel like filler the campaign
sets up an enormous undertaking against
the vex with infinite timelines and
computer simulations and the mysterious
Warlock Osiris mixed up in it all but
with the torso our run time the missions
rushed through the interesting concepts
and usher you into a simple final battle
that is essentially scripted it's also
not enough time to fully understand
Osiris as a character which is
disappointing considering he's only ever
been mentioned in destiny lore before
now if I don't stop the vex there won't
be anything to come back to I'm doing
this for the part of us
the beautiful and varied infinite forest
of vex creation designed to simulate
timelines and their infinite
permutations is the most interesting
addition to the expansion but even then
the story doesn't task you with
exploring it instead shepherding you
through areas to find codes and things
that smarter NPCs can use to pinpoint
your next destination for you scanning
other than the infinite forest the new
destination mercury is simply
uninteresting to explore it's a small
circular map with one new public event
to try out a new vendor and a handful of
chests and loss sectors foundation of
exploration established in the base game
is still good here having a variety of
options to choose from does make things
feel less repetitive but it feels like
busywork with little to do at the
highest level that extends to the new
strikes which are almost direct copies
of two of the story missions nothing
more than another way to kill time the
biggest problem with curse of Osiris is
that it locks the hardest activities
including the prestige nightfall in the
prestige raid behind its new power level
cap the recommended power for those
activities is 3:30 which you can't reach
if you don't have the curse of Osiris
DLC so if you don't get the DLC you
suddenly don't have access to something
you used to be able to do it's also
frustrating if you do get curse of
Osiris because the higher level
requirement doesn't fundamentally change
these activities new heroic adventures
add nightfall style modifiers to the
adventures on Mercury but those missions
aren't begging to be replayed the main
incentive to do it at all is to unlock a
lost prophecy quest from the npc brother
Vance which is one of the most tedious
consumable gathering chores in all of
destiny 2 if you do manage to gather ten
of the necessary item through repeating
public events and finding chests you
unlock the forge where you can craft
legendary vex weapons but for anyone
besides the most dedicated players
there's no compelling reason to do all
of this unless you want to redo old
missions on hardware difficulties in
order to get loot to use when you do
them again while some of the new loot is
worth collecting my favorites of the
ones I've found are a legendary
automatic scout rifle and the broken but
ridiculously fun prometheus lens exotic
you'll likely get a lot of duplicate
before you get anything you actually
want to use because the main reward for
everything you do is shiny new loot the
frustratingly high drop rate of
duplicates makes grinding more
disappointing than satisfying the
gunplay feels as great as ever though so
it can be fun to experiment with new
weapons but it's not enough to sustain
an expansion that adds little outside of
extra busy work the raid layer while
shorter than a typical Destiny's raid is
the one late-game addition that's worth
trying eater of worlds is set on
leviathan the setting of destiny two's
first raid with a different boss and
separate areas to explore it features a
mix of destiny style puzzles including a
platforming sequence and fun with orbs
using careful teamwork to solve puzzles
is rewarding in ways the story and
simple strikes can't be and combining
that with the right loadout and strong
shooting skills showcases what destiny
could be but in almost every respect
cursive Osiris doesn't elevate destiny
to beyond what it was it launched
especially for lapse players the same
old activities reskin for an
unremarkable new setting feel more like
chores than ever and the interesting
ideas in the infinite forest aren't it
all use their potentials there's still
some fun to be had in finding new
weapons and maybe tackling the raid lair
but reaching that point is so tedious
that it hardly feels worth doing there's
something else in here with me
and coded holo images big ones
definitely vex
look I can't decrypt those files or open
the gate we need backup
we need Ike aura good idea right